oh my god are you kidding me
lord take me away
stephanie what is going on
no seriously she lost it you know what
you know what this is over
stephanie and ryan got into this huge
argument because he slept with her
without a condom
i know it's wild but she did ask him to
use one because
she doesn't trust him please tell me why
did you
pretend to put a condom on and then not
no
but you're crazy yeah okay i'm saying
i'm crazy bingo
all right there we go let's blame it on
stephanie there he hung up perfect
i got him blocked up i gotta block him
and i am going to bed
she did not go to bed she should have
but
she ended up calling her psychic and
ryan's cousin harris
there is so much to unpack here so
i'm just going to save my opinions for
now and we'll talk about them in just a
few
plus we're also going to take a look at
how brandon and julia's pregnancy scare
had mrs betty and mr ron shook
no no no no there's no
you are not it was not positive it
wasn't positive be
truthful this is not a game this is not
a joke i need to know
julia i need to know
yes or no okay you're not pregnant
brandon and julia play too much hey 90
day fans fam
it's melisia let's go ahead and get
right into stephanie
and this unraveling that we witnessed
after 10 months of not seeing each other
stephanie and ryan got intimate
i'm guessing she finally got that
quickie she was complaining about
a few episodes ago i haven't seen you in
10 months i mean so i was kind of
thinking
well i wouldn't mind a quickie
you would have thought she would be
happy but here's the problem
according to stephanie ryan faked as if
he used protection
which completely set her off
hey brian are you afraid of the truth
ryan
are you afraid of the truth you're good
you're good
what you're you're good that you slept
with me last night with no condom
after i said to you i don't trust your
ass
you got it out crinkle crinkle crinkle i
thought we were good
you know when i said you i need
lubricant you're like wait there's no
rubber
why would you do that to me
you're trying to embarrass me i i'm not
trying to embarrass i'm trying to call
you
out ryan you got your cat when it was
who's money
she said with whose money yeah she's
definitely trying to embarrass him at
this point
now look i get stephanie's concern stds
are nothing to play with
so she has the right to be upset but
according to ryan
this is nothing new he says every time
stephanie comes to visit him
she says she doesn't trust him she
brings condoms
but they never use them honestly
the condom and lubricant conversation
was
a bit tmi for me i was mainly focused on
how stephanie was reacting to all of
this
now i see why they say dramatic people
have dramatic lives
it was a bit much i mean
20 20 eat my ass
don't you lie to me ryan you want to
talk about life
so why would you lie about harris oh my
god are you
kidding me
lord take me away
you know what you know what this is over
this is over off
i'm gonna go find myself a little cabana
boy i got tons of nice slides and
slippers and man
i've got thousands of dollars of watches
and
tons of clothes a cabana boy stephanie
what this made me wonder does stephanie
have
anyone around her that will sit her down
and tell her the truth
not hint at the truth but say it this
is a beautiful successful woman who
continues to entertain people that
obviously are using her which makes her
look like a fool
unfortunately on national television oh
god
[Music]
my life is a show right after this fight
with ryan
she called his cousin harris which is
exactly the same thing she did last time
and we know how that ended what's up
who are you you're not gonna believe
what your cousin pulled on me
you know i have very good reason not to
trust him right
that's right what's up what's up with
him
is he not right in the head i thought
you got so much time here
can you come here and see me i mean i
know it's asking a lot but
i need to see your face
okay please call me tomorrow please
first of all stephanie don't beg anyone
to come see you
second of all harris is a snake
each time he called her baby it
literally made my
skin crawl after she got off the phone
with him
she called her psychic friend who i'm
sure
means well but her premonitions have not
helped thus far
do i need to see harris before i leave
this country or do i just get on a plane
i think harris does care about you but i
also think he has other motives he's got
other agendas
i mean the best advice i can give you is
forget ryan
be safe i'll be thinking of you all
right i love you i'll talk to you
probably tomorrow
bye okay hopefully i'm gonna see harris
tomorrow
i mean this is all happening so fast i
mean i just broke up with my fiance
marie is giving me signals that yes she
sees a lot of great signs with harris
i really put a lot of heart and soul
into what maria tells me
so maybe it's meant to be with harris
[Music]
she didn't say that okay i take back
what i said about maria the psychic
she gives good advice stephanie just
doesn't listen
or should i say she only hears what she
wants to hear
because she totally forgot about the
part where maria said he has
other motives which you don't need to be
psychic to see
here's a tease of what happens with
stephanie next week
i've dedicated three and a half years of
my life to a
liar so now that ryan's gone
i really need to see a friendly face
wow right harris
wow took the words right out of my mouth
stephanie should be careful
all right let's move on to brandon and
julia who we know
don't like to use protection either this
episode they had a pregnancy scare
and brandon came up with the bright idea
to tell his parents
julia was throwing up before she even
took a pregnancy test
i think we need to tell my parents about
you getting sick
yeah why
brandon i need to be first
need no pregnant i'm or not and next
talk with parents
yeah well no you're not think so
no i i don't think so of course
this makes no sense but it's also not a
surprise
because brandon has told his parents
unnecessary information before
remember this from the birth control
conversation
yeah i guess i mean you guys can do
other things to make sure that doesn't
happen
i don't know if i really want to take on
that kind of responsibility
either that kind of responsibility
yeah birth control and stuff like that
i don't get it what do you mean
what are you saying that um
[Music]
i guess we're not being safe you're not
what that's not good why why tell your
parents that when you know
how they're going to react i'm thinking
either a producer tells brandon to say
all of these things
or he just really feels the need to tell
ron and betty everything
julia has been has been feeling a little
bit sick
[Laughter]
what are you saying oh uh
so she's throwing up this morning really
yeah we don't know anything yet so you
can go to the drugstore and market one
of those little test things can't you
i'd have probably already been there and
got it
i would have never said anything to
anybody until i went out and got that
test and she took it i mean i appreciate
the communication
but i wouldn't have done that i honestly
don't know anybody that would have done
that
so i'm with you ron i'm also really
surprised at how calm
brandon's parents were they didn't freak
out that much
although betty did give julia the death
stare
luckily the pregnancy test came back
negative
but brandon and julia decided to milk
the moment
just a little bit well
we took a test today well yeah
and
no no you're kidding me you're kidding
me
i wish i was no no no you're kidding me
you're kidding me no no
no no there's no you are not it was not
positive
it wasn't positive julia don't are you
positive i'm not anything i want to hear
julia tell me that
okay you're not pregnant
brandon and julia were wrong for that
all betty could say was
no no no no no no
no no there's snow like no was gonna
stop the baby well now that there is no
baby to worry about
next week julia is going wedding dress
shopping
oh here she comes i feel excited because
first time go store and look dress
a little bit flatter you like that one
yeah random place more emoji
please talk what do you want what what
do you like i like all of them
and that's why they say never take your
man with you wedding dress shopping
they can only act interested for so long
julia looks
beautiful by the way i can't wait to see
that
alright 90 day fans fam to stay updated
on all the latest news coming out the 90
day universe
make sure you stick with e.t because we
are covering it all
i'll see you next time